hey what's up guys mkbhd here and today
we're going to be talking about 4k
explained so you've probably heard 4k
tossed around quite a bit in the past
couple of weeks or months especially
during ces at the beginning of january
this year 4k has been sort of a buzzword
but what does 4k mean exactly well
there's not a whole lot to technically
explain but there is a lot to it so 4k
is a resolution really and it's measured
in pixels just like every other
resolution starting at the smallest you
can see smartphones nowadays the average
smartphone is about 1280x720
so that's a 1280x720 we call it a 720p
display your average laptop say which
has a slightly bigger display is
typically somewhere around 1440 by 900
somewhere around there then you get up
to the larger desktop displays and these
are usually around 1920 by 1080 these
are called 1080p displays 4k displays
are somewhere around 4 000 pixels across
by 2000 pixels down now i say somewhere
around that because 4k actually varies
there isn't an exact standard yet but
the closest thing we have to a standard
for 4k is called uhd and uhd stands for
ultra high definition and that is 3840
by 2160. that is a lot of pixels there
are more pixels on a 4k display than
there are seconds in three months so if
you're gonna try to count all these
pixels you're gonna take a while now in
terms of pixel density i already did a
video about pixel density but we already
know that basically the higher the pixel
density of a display the better it looks
the more clear the more sharp it looks
because there are more pixels for you to
look at to make the image look good so
this also depends on the distance you
are viewing that item from so we'll
start off with smartphones if you're
looking at a 1280x720 display a couple
inches from your face you don't really
use your smartphone that far away from
your face so you really need it to be a
high pixel density because i'm pretty
close i can see a lot of pixels if it's
bad so given that we hold these guys a
foot or less away from our face i'll
give the average smartphone an average
pixel density of 300 ppi or 300 pixels
per inch a laptop since you hold it
further from your face doesn't have to
be quite as high a pixel density so if
you're looking at maybe a 15 inch laptop
with that 1440 by 900 resolution you are
looking at a pixel density of about 120
ppi which is good because it's already
you know two feet away from your face
now so you can't really see all the
pixels at 120 ppi so 120 is pretty good
for a laptop when you get to a huge
display that you're sitting kind of far
away from like a 1080p 55 inch tv you
get to a pixel density of 40 40 ppi now
that seems low because you know we were
just talking about 300 ppi phones but
sitting 10 10 15 20 feet away from it
you're never going to be able to see
those pixels at 40 ppi so it's a really
high crisp resolution display but that's
just 1080p now i'm sure you've all as a
kid or at least sometime in your life
walked up to a tv and looked at all the
red green and blue pixels that is called
the subpixel matrix basically when
you're looking at these pixels those are
the colors that make up the images that
you see on your tv in order to see those
you had to get up like all the way up to
the tv and look at it from a couple of
inches away and then you could see all
the pixels with a 4k tv you will
actually never be able to see those red
green and blue pixels a 4k 55 inch tv
comes in over a hundred ppi which means
you can be inches from it like a laptop
and still not be able to see the pixels
standing five eight 12 feet away from a
4k tv will look flat out incredible
really really sharp now i don't have a
4k tv personally but i saw a ton of them
at ces 2013. you might have seen my
video recap of that event if you haven't
it's down below the like button on this
video but there were a ton of 4k tvs
playing 4k content like videos and video
games on these tvs and everyone who
walked by pretty much paused for a
second and stared at it because it was
that off striking it was really good
looking it's almost like a little bit
below that level of looking through a
window it's just sort of a surreal sort
of realism you get especially if you
have a high frame rate a really good 4k
video looks incredible on any 4k tv now
the first problem with 4k tvs is that
they're a little bit expensive
okay not a little bit expensive they are
really expensive not six seven thousand
dollars i'm talking new car 25 000 30
000 us dollars expensive so these are
crazy out of this world expensive right
now but again we saw them on the show
floor at ces for the past two years
that's kind of where this sort of
innovation starts and maybe in another
two or three years it'll be in our
living room but the other problem with
4k at least right now if you want to
call it a problem is that there is
barely any 4k content remember when we
saw 3d tvs at ces and they all had those
awesome 3d videos and the 3d glasses but
nobody makes 3d content
well sony is sort of pushing the way for
more 4k content to be produced and there
are some awesome cameras out there i
have a link description below that will
shoot 4k so sony's pushing the way a lot
of big companies are sort of following
behind and making you know it easier for
you to get 4k content into your home
even if you don't have a 4k display it
still looks really good on a 1080p
display and a
2560x1600 display so basically what that
means is you know tv shows aren't 4k
today but if this keeps up you know the
past two years have been good if they
keep going it's gonna be really good and
hopefully we'll see some awesome 4k
stuff in the future so the largest hub
out there right now for 4k content is of
course the internet specifically web
video like youtube but the thing is
people who are going out and shooting
videos on the red scarlet and the red
epic and 4k cameras putting it on
youtube it gets compressed way down to
you know 50 megabits per second tops the
bit rate gets lowered it gets compressed
and you don't get the full quality of it
watching it on youtube that being said i
have a video linked in the description
below where you can watch a 4k video on
vimeo and vimeo seems to have the sort
of clearest compression or littlest
compression at all so you can watch that
video on your display i guarantee you
it's going to look great and you can
leave a comment below if you enjoyed it
it's a pretty great video and
it's just really really crisp and clear
you can see every little detail and
everything so if you want to watch 4k
content the web is the place to be
youtube not so much but vimeo is a great
place to find it also fun fact when you
view a 4k video on youtube there is a
button just for 4k so you know how you
see 240p 360p 480p 720p and 1080p
there's a button that says original for
anything over 1080p so if you upload a
4k 5k 8k video you get a special button
so yeah there you go that's 4k explained
it's pretty basic but again it's pretty
awesome i'm hoping someday in the future
we'll have you know 4k displays in the
palm of our hands playing 4k games we
saw nvidia's project shield which was
outputting 4k video from a handheld
console to a 4k tv so you know that's a
step in the right direction hopefully
we'll see more stuff like that very soon
let me know if you guys are excited for
4k or if that's so yesterday and that 8k
tv at ces is the future
either way thanks for watching guys and
i will talk to you guys in the next
video which will get started with the
long-awaited hackintosh pro project
that's finally getting started so thumbs
up if you're ready for that thanks for
watching
peace
you